[Music]
let's go to buffalo new york adam is
there adam how can we help
hey guys how you doing here today uh
we're having a blast how are you sir
not too bad a little stressed so hoping
you guys can help me out here all right
um
just to give you a little bit of
background here so uh earlier this week
my my mother came to me and asked me to
help her with her finances doing a
monthly budget and getting things in
order as well too i'm going over some
general information with her i found out
that they have about 65k in debt but
they're also looking to retire in the
next three to five years
and
i told them to go to a financial advisor
uh they're a little untrusting of people
outside the family when it comes to
money so i'm just looking for some
information something that i can relay
back to them
as far as how to kind of get out of this
step before they go to look in to get
into retirement sure how familiar are
you with our baby steps
uh very familiar i'm actually following
myself right now great are they familiar
with dave and the ramsay show and
financial peace and or any of this stuff
or is this all foreign to them
uh kind of i brought that up to her when
we initially talked and i found out all
this found out all this information so
it's relatively new to them okay give us
a quick snapshot of their financial
picture
you said 65 000 in debt how much do they
make collectively uh
collectively uh a year probably 100k so
100k
and do they have 401ks pension plans
what what do they currently have in the
form of retirement accounts
yep in retirement account they probably
have around 400 uh 400k in their 401ks
uh and then with pensions combined when
they do retire they'll probably be
making 2100 um 2100 a month with their
pensions and what's their housing
situation
uh the house is paid off for but they do
have a home equity loan that the 65k is
tied up in right now okay and then what
is the rest of the 65k home equity loan
what else
home equity loan uh with the home equity
loan they put um a couple i believe like
5 10 years ago they redid their kitchen
uh which is probably i believe around
between 30 to 50k i don't have that oh
okay i'm sorry so so the 65 is just the
heloc
there's nothing outside of that
correct oh okay gotcha all right
um well i mean what you've got to sit
down with them and you got to sit down
and explain
the baby steps to them right i mean just
literally walk them through this baby
step one is the thousand dollars
uh in their savings account and then
everything else and they're they're
obviously older
so gazelle intensity to go we're paying
off the heloc right everything is it's
165 000
snowball we're getting after right and
so we just got to take that on every
month and they've got you know x amount
of years that they want to retire and so
that paid for home plus their 401k
and the pension all puts them in a
pretty decent space if they have no debt
and they were to knock that out quickly
and start investing
as quickly as possible would you say
that's true is their son
yes definitely and what i'm wondering is
is do they stop investing in their 401k
and basically the money that they're
putting into the 401k invest that into
the into the debt and once they knock
that off absolutely
yeah they pause they pause on that
because they have a paid for house
right
and they've got a pension coming their
way so pause everything
and they are knocking this out and walk
them through this help them with the
budget if they'll if if they're willing
and i don't hear that there's any
tension on this sit down with them and
do a basic budget with them walk them
through fpu and get them hooked up on
every dollar literally do it with them
and get them automated to where every
extra dime is going into that heloc and
they'll knock that out pretty quickly
and if if either one of them can get
some overtime or some side work or how
much could you sell do they have 10 15
grand of stuff laying around the house i
mean that's the gazelle intensity to try
to knock this out
sooner rather than later
gotcha yeah and they have about four
grand in their savings account um should
we drain that down to the one the 1k
that you guys you know talk about baby
set dump number one put that towards the
65k and then look to invest in that
later yep today so now they're down to
62. show them that and adam i would
start the conversation with
you guys have this end goal of retiring
sooner rather than later
you're going to have to change the way
you live to do this safely and smartly
that's right yeah
i see it affecting their their daily
life and it will and stuff like that as
well too and attention on their their
you know their marriage as well i just
want to see them financially free and
get back to the
happy you go lucky themselves they are
you know you can't want this more than
they do
correct
you want them to have the freedom you're
feeling as you walk through this stuff
and you want them to have the optimism
that you have walking through this stuff
and they have to want it you can't force
it on them you can't make them do it you
can show them reality which is you've
got a math problem here
and you all gonna have to change your
lives a little bit if you want and
here's what retirement's going to look
like by the way here is your budget
so when my mom was talking about hey i'm
thinking about starting to have a
conversation about retirement the first
question i asked was can you all afford
to do that
because you want to retire all you want
that's a math problem first and then an
identity and what am i going to do next
problem second so when someone's like
i'm thinking about retiring first
question is can you even is that even a
possibility for you and some people
think they just magically can retire
when they get to 62 or 65
and math says otherwise right
gotcha yeah adam you're you're good man
um
hang on the line let's uh let's gift
them with a year of financial peace
university let's get them going and uh
john that's great advice tell them to
watch the videos together yeah i was
gonna say how does he how does he
approach that he's gonna gift them with
us it's our gift to him to give to his
parents what's the great way to kind of
posture that i'm coming over to watch
this with you oh okay good i'll come
watch it with you great and here's what
i'm doing in my house and it's making a
huge difference you've invited me into
this conversation um and so i'm just
gonna show it to you i'm gonna give you
ringside seat to it and i'll do it with
you yeah i love it